now there's general since you were last
here Olivia : I feel like our own Olivia
Colman now has an Oscar supporting no
actual full-on best ever yeah I don't
think it's best ever
I think it is they're finishing it now
they've stopped yeah you won but it must
have been a bonkers night I actually
can't remember it when we were saying
backstage we met can't remember she was
in the days after she won a huge night
for you as well I mean black panther was
up for how many or what seven I yeah
something like that yeah it was it was a
great you know I expected it to be
just a normal night he was like there's
a whole bunch of hype about being it to
ask isn't being nominated but there was
some magic in the air it was a real
sparkle you know yeah cuz Richard what
was it like for you sitting at home
nothing it's business as usual
and I look forward to a lifetime of not
being nobody must be nice cheering
Olivia because you guys have known each
other for a really long time I why
bitterly resented it yes well I am at
college live next to Olivia's husband
yeah it's not a great story but it kind
of ends boring you'll be nominated a
couple of times for the Oscars yeah I
didn't win him
no but you've got nominated nobody said
in Wynnum why you don't enjoy events
like no it's not that I'm not very good
at sitting still so you have to have
your harem no no I'm really not
so it's and their long events yes they
do but the great thing about the Oscars
is that the bar is just they're just
behind there and so almost all the time
everyone's in the wrong no one's sitting
in it that's true there are no one works
of seating for Lilith hundreds oh really
although everybody is getting bladder
documentary I hope Cheers
was
[Music]